6 octobre 1789 louis saez remet les clés
à son ministre de la guerre on faire la
tournée pas tâcher de me sauver mon
pauvre versailles choses extraordinaires
au coeur de la révolution le château
comme un navire abandonné continue sur
son air pendant trois ans on
l'entretient ont leur pain on le
bichonne
jamais il n'a été aussi propre aussi
beau mais cela ne dure pas on commence
par vendre le mobilier
puis charles de la croix le père du
peintre réclame sa destruction à cor et
à cri on propose diverses affectations
hôpital auspices écoles finalement louis
philippe à l'idée de faire de ce symbole
de la royauté le temple de la
réconciliation nationale
voici l'inauguration de son fameux musée
d'histoire dédiés comme le proclament
les frontons à toutes les gloires de la
france le château et sauver
définitivement mais à l'intérieur la
casse est considérable les charmant
appartement du xviiie siècle sont
remplacés par ces enfilade de pièces
monotone que les conservateurs actuels
ont eu bien du mérite à rajeunir et à
égayer
en revanche toute l'histoire de france
des croisades à la guerre de 14 et l'a
accroché au mur
six mille tableaux 2000 sculptures les
événements les hommes les batailles
héroïques c'est d'un coût 150 salles
fermées pour travaux depuis 20 ans qui
sont livrés à l'appétit des écoliers
un jour vous précisez pas inaugurer sont
mises en 1837 il ya eu 25 mille
personnes et dix mille 10 nice se sont
poursuivies à fossa pendant des mois et
des mois et de que nous ouvrons nos
salles historiques les gens se
précipitent les haines l'histoire et il
aime voir la façon dont elle est
racontée images et en couleurs
et pourquoi ont-elles été fermée si
longtemps que nous avons eues
premièrement à restaurer un certain
nombre de ces salles et deuxièmement
nous avons des problèmes de gardiennage
le 7 août immense vous le connaissez
nous ne pouvons pas tout ouvrir en même
temps et c'est un de nos gros problème
est ce que le 2 juin toutes les salles
du musée sont ouvertes pas tout mais les
deux tiers ou les trois quarts ce qui
est déjà énorme mais qui remplit
largement la journée d'un touriste
solide et quand le musée extractives
ouvert complètement d'ici un an un an et
demi il prend maintenant